sont définis c'est ça le tente on leur a
fait on veut des garanties alors ça sert
à rien
pour l'activer certaines des idées alors
oui les grèves à la télé et en ces temps
troublés ils étaient plus d'un millier
c'est à votre que le chemin des salles
de cinéma des champs elysées qui vous
revient avec ce drop juste avec des
jeunes à pied c'est quoi ces chaussures
bruyantes des nike
cette balade comme dans des pantoufles
je quitte plus pourquoi vous avez choisi
ce film là pour voir michel serrault on
voit le bonheur est dans le pré on est
anticipée
on va voir parce que moi je viens des
filles qui se passe sur la campagne
des choses comme ça même à la foule au
il a dû bruno bien pour gaucher de
goûter à celui ci ont détruit nos
excellents ça détend bien pour l'époque
nous vivants salle complètement rose où
il veut être très bon film je trouve ça
très très bien si complètement immoral
ça fait du bien ça faisait longtemps que
je n'avais pas eu d'aussi bon coeur
c'était extra c'est un bol de fraîcheur
dans cette grisaille du bonheur
aujourd'hui technique
alors monsieur par le fumet super g en
gare c'est vrai à soissons m'a vraiment
vraiment très mal apprécié si vous
pouviez dire non à michel serrault
l'abri guerrier quoi aller jeter les
traire les profits tu profites c'est la
seul mot de la fin